[Music]
it's time for ETS social study your
quick look at what the Stars are posting
online Nicki Minaj bared her booty on
Instagram and these racy
behind-the-scenes pics from her new
music video light my body up while model
Ashley Graham also shared some sexy
behind-the-scenes bikini shots from her
Sports Illustrated swimsuit shoot in
Fiji
what are you harboring cuz God knows I
would really love to hear this sterling
K Brown has been harboring some rippling
abs that's for sure
but this is a star took to the gram
Sunday to share this steamy shirtless
selfie we're all in a good place
blac Chyna's body definitely is the 28
year old model took to snapchat over the
weekend to flaunt her ever-shrinking bod
Jai revealed she's lost over 50 pounds
since giving birth to daughter dream
Kardashian in November and she's 11
pounds shy of her goal weight of 130 Hey
so we wanted you guys to hear first
meanwhile Kourtney Kardashian got
slammed by her Instagram followers after
she posted this pic of daughter Penelope
and son rain sitting on top of their dad
Scott Disick's brand new 122 thousand
dollar car one person commented quote
sister got robbed and here she is
chucking her babies in the mix I mean
I'm so happy
[Music]
you